monsieur
prés
la séance est
ouverte le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le
procès-verbal est donc adopté sous les
réserves
d'usage Monsieur le Premier Ministre au
nom du Sénat tout entier je tiens à
nouveau à vous féliciter pour votre
nomination et à vous souhaiter la
bienvenue au sein de notre assemblée
dans vos nouvelles fonctions depuis le
début de la législature votre
prédécesseur madame ellisabeth borne a
témoigné lors de nos séances de
questions d'actualité du une présence
constante à laquelle nous avons été je
vous l'ai dit particulièrement sensible
et que je tiens une nouvelle fois à
saluer je souhaite également la
bienvenue aux membres du
gouvernement avec une attention
particulière pour la ministre en charge
des relations avec le Parlement Marie
Lebec Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres le
Sénat est le reflet de nos territoires
dans leur diversité sur ces ban siège
des élus expérimentés à l'écoute de nos
concito citoyen nos collectivités
territoriales je forme donc le vœux
monsieur le Premier ministre que vous
soyez attentif au Sénat je crois que le
bicameris j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
hier soir est une chance pour la
démocratie et l'équilibre de nos
institution Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues notre ordre du jour
appelle les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement je vous rappelle que la
séance s'est retransmise en direct sur
Public Sénat et sur sur notre site
internet chacun sera attentif au cours
de nos échanges des valeurs qui sont
pour nous très importantes le respect le
respect des uns et des autres mais aussi
le respect du temps de parole et je vais
donner la parole tout de suite à madame
la Présidente Cécile Garman pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste canqui madame la Présidente
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier ministre
mes chers collègues monsieur le Premier
ministre vous tentez d'incarner un
changement mais la seule nouveauté c'est
que ce remanimement marque l'ancrage
dans votre nouveau monde de casse du
service public un monde fait pour les
riches un monde d'oppression pour les
salariés un monde qui exclut au lieu de
rassembler cette politique génère une
crise démocratique profonde d'ailleurs
le président de la République n'a
toujours pas de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale cette question
n'est ni politicienne ni secondaire
c'est le socle du fonctionnement de nos
institutions vous ne pouvez plus faire
jouer l'autoritarisme en abusant de 493
comme en 2023 vous engagez-vous à user
de cet article ou laisser faire le débat
parlementaire monsieur le Premier
ministre c'est le gouvernement qui
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation selon l'article 20 de la
Constitution et non le président de la
République c'est fondamental car si le
gouvernement se mu en un cabinet
d'exécutant sans vote de confiance du
Parlement c'est l'édifice
institutionnelle qui s'effondre Emmanuel
Macron prend tout en main des rencontres
de Saint-Denis jusqu'à hier lors de sa
conférence de politique générale mais il
n'est pas responsable devant le
Parlement vous devez donc Monsieur le
Premier Ministre demander un vote de
confiance à l'Assemblée nationale comme
l'indique l'article 49-1 de la
Constitution et au vu du rôle du Sénat
face au blocage de l'Assemblée nationale
vous devez aussi vous soumettre à son
vote en déclenchant l'article 49- 4 y
compris au regard de la place que le
Sénat a pris ces derniers temps en
commission mixte paritaire aujourd'hui
c'est la confusion la gesticulation
médiatique pour masquer l'accélération
autoritaire de la politique libérale
notre peuple a besoin de reprendre la
main a besoin de clarté à soif de
justice votre mandat doit être soumis au
vote des représentants du peuple sinon
vous serez qu'illusion je vous repose la
question Monsieur le Premier Ministre
allez-vous engager la confiance pour
vous répondre la parole à Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs madame la Présidente
quickerman c'est la première fois que
j'ai l'occasion de m'exprimer devant le
Sénat en tant que Premier ministre et
vous me permettrez donc de vous dire que
et je l'ai dit au président Larcher que
j'ai eu au téléphone le soir de ma
nomination nous nous sommes revus depuis
j'ai un très grand respect et même je le
dis une très grande admiration pour le
travail qui est mené ici au Sénat j'ai
pu le mesurer dans différentes fonctions
gouvernementales que j'ai occupé ces
dernières années en tant que secrétaire
d'État à la Jeunesse porte-parole du
gouvernement davantage pour les
questions d'actualité des longues nuits
sur le projet de loi de finances avec le
rapporteur Husson avec le président
renal avec chacune et chacun d'entre
vous et puis au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse évidemment
avec le président Lafond notamment mais
aussi beaucoup d'entre vous extrêmement
mobilisés sur ces questionsl j'ai
toujours été je le crois très à l'écoute
de ce qui était porté par les sénatrices
et par les sénateurs du fait de
l'expérience qui est la vôtre de la
représentativité qui est la vôre de nos
territoires dans leur très grande
diversité des
propositions parfois détonnantes et
c'est aussi pour ça que nous nous
réunissons en tout cas toujours
constructive et c'est vraiment l'état
d'esprit qui m'anime et que je
poursuivrai ici avec vous
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire je ferai
ma déclaration de politique générale à
l'Assemblée nationale le 30 janvier
prochain parce que je souhaite d'ici là
pouvoir rencontrer l'ensemble des
groupes représentés au Parlement
président de président de groupe les
forces vives de la nation les
organisations syndicales les
associations d'élus locaux je souhaite
aussi me rendre sur le terrain dans des
échange très direct avec les Français
avant la présentation de cette
déclaration de politique générale vous
m'interrogez madame la la présidente sur
une question qui relève de l'Assemblée
nationale mais je vais évidemment y
répondre j'ai d'ailleurs et nous y avons
d'ailleurs déjà répondu est-ce qu'il y a
une majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale non nous le savons est-ce
qu'il y a besoin d'un vote pour le
démontrer non je ne crois pas non plus
est-ce qu'il y a des Français qui se
lèvent le matin en se demandant est-ce
qu'il y aura ou pas un vote sur la
déclaration de politique générale du
Premier ministre je ne crois pas non
plus je pense qu'il y a des Français qui
se lèvent le matin en attendant de
savoir ce que nous allons faire pour
valoriser le travail des classes
moyennes qui sont toujours rendez-vous
de leur responsabilité et qui attendent
qu'on agisse pour elle pour réarmer nos
services publics et notamment l'école et
la santé pour assurer la sécurité en
tout lieux sur le territoire et pour
agir pour la transition écologique c'est
ça les préoccupations des Français et
pour le coup c'est peut-être une
révélation que je vous fais ça sera au
cœur de la déclaration de politique
générale que je ferai à l'Assemblée
nationale comme c'est vous le savez
l'usage cette déclaration sera lu ici au
Sénat en même temps que je la
prononcerai à l'Assemblée nationale mais
j'ai proposé au président Larcher nous
ne sommes pas encore reparlés mais j'ai
proposé c'est peut-être moins l'usage de
venir dans la foulée de cette
déclaration de politique générale devant
vous pour prononcer une intervention
propre au Sénat évidemment sur les
enjeux que je viens d'évoquer qui
concernne tous les
Français mais je crois que la situation
que traverse notre pays les défis que
traverse le monde et en tout cas l'état
d'esprit qui est le mien commande que
nous puissions avoir un débat ensemble
ici au Sénat et c'est l'engagement que
je prends devant vous je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Hervé Moret pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
Monsieur le Premier Ministre hier le
président de la République a évoqué lors
de sa conférence de presse un grand
nombre de sujets allant de l'école à la
santé du pouvoir d' achat à la sécurité
entre autres il n'en revanche pas ou
peut évoquer un sujet qui nous paraît
pourtant important la situation de nos
finances publiques nous connaissons
pourtant un record de dett qui nous met
sur le podium européen des pays les plus
endettés une charge de la dette qui va
bondir de 50 % d'ici à 2027 et un
déficit qui sera le deuxè plus important
de la zone euro un certain nombre des
annonces du président vont même encore
aggraver cette situation avec la général
du service national universel qui
pourrait coûter plus de 3 milliards par
an et la baisse de 2 milliards des
impôts maises questions sont donc très
simples à combien chiffrez-vous les
annonces du président de la République
comment comptez-vous les financer queles
sont les intention réelle du
gouvernement en terme de maîtrise des
finances publiques souvent évoqué mais
jamais
réalisé pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'économie et des
finances
Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire merci monsieur le
Président profiter de cet accueil
allez-y j'ai peur que ça ne dure pas
tout le temps mais j'en profite pour
vous adresser à mon tour mes meilleurs
vœux à tous les sénateurs présents et au
président du Sénat
sénatrice sénatrice et
sénateur monsieur Moray nous nous
connaissons bien nous avons été élus du
même territoire pendant une quinzaine
d'années et vous savez que j'ai
l'habitude de faire les choses en temps
et en heure nous avons en
2017 avec les gouvernements précédents
rétablir nos finances publiques j'avais
dit que nous reviendrions sous les 3 %
de déficit que nous sortirions de la
procédure pour déficit public excessif
j'ai tenu parole nous avons ensuite eu à
faire face à deux crises successives
majeur le covid et la crise
inflationniste vous toutes et vous tous
ici vous avez appelé à une protection de
nos capacités de production une
protection de nos salariés une
protection de nos PME et nos TPE nous
l'avons fait vous avez appelé une
protection des plus modeste face à la
crise inflationniste et à la flambée des
prix du gaz et du prix de l'électricité
nous l'avons fait maintenant nous
revenons à la normale nous sortons d'une
situation exceptionnelle et je partage
totalement votre ambition et je tiendrai
parole nous devons rétablir nos finances
publiques accélérer le désendettement du
pays et réduire nos déficits pour tenir
la première marche de 2024 4,4 % de
déficit et accélérer ensuite et je crois
avoir dit les choses très clairement il
y a quelques semaines en matière de
finances publiqu le plus dur est devant
nous allons devoir prendre des décisions
fortes et courageuses pour établir nos
finances publiques et et comme je sais
que vous avez très bien écouté le
président de la République hier vous
aurez noté qu'il en a déjà annoncé au
moins deux la première il a confirmé que
nous allions sortir du bouclier
énergétique sur le gaz comme sur
l'électricité parce que je l'ai dit hier
ici au Sénat à situation exceptionnelle
mesure exceptionnelle mais dès lors que
nous sortons de la situation
exceptionnelle il faut revenir à la
normale et mettre fin au bouclier
énergétique sur le gaz sur électricité
il l'a fait également sur la franchise
qui va passer de CEN à 1 € sur les
médicaments j'aurai l'occasion sur la
base des revues de dépenses publiques de
proposer au Premier ministre et au
président de la République des décision
forte et courageuse je n'ai aucun doute
monsieur le sénateur que vous les
soutiendrez monsieur
Moret merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre bon vous avez pas
tout à fait répondu à mes questions mais
je je ne m'attendais pas une autre
situation je voudrais simplement dire
qu'il me paraît difficile en matière de
finances publiques d'être dans dans le
en même temps temps on peut pas parler
d'indépendance financière comme l'a fait
le président de la République et
continuer à dépenser et à s'endetter
chaque jour davantage vous avez
récemment dit qu'il faudrait faire 12
milliards d'économie le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que les mesures
évoquées par le Président de la
République où cell évoqué par le Premier
ministre qui a annoncé 32 milliards
supplémentaires pour la santé ne vont
pas dans le bon sens et de toute
évidence la valal ce des milliards
continue et la loi de programmation des
finances publiques à peine voté S déjà
caduc je voudrais juste rappeler que le
Sénat lors de la du projet de loi de
finan pour 2024 avait proposé 7
milliards d'économie et 2 milliards de
recettes supplémentaires dont le
gouvernement n'a pas tenu compte donc je
ne peux pour conclure qu'inciter le
gouvernement comme l'a fait le président
du Sénat à l'égard du Premier ministre
hier soir a écouter davantage les
propositions du Sénat je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
madame PM pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité
territoire merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ce raniimement
gouvernemental acte la continuité d'une
ligne politique de droite mais nous
aurons le temps de le questionner une
fois la feuille de route présentée mais
la situation à Gaza elle ne peut plus
attendre en 100 jours 1 % de Gazaoui a
été tué soit un taux de mortalité
quotidien supérieur à celui de n'importe
quel conflit armé du 21e siècle
sans compter les personnes ensevelies
blessées 85 % de la population déplacée
lors de la récente audience à la Cour
internationale de justice concernant la
sisine de l'Afrique du Sud contre Israël
une des avocates a déclaré c'est le
premier génocide de l'histoire où les
victimes diffusent leur propre
destruction en temps réel dans l'espoir
désespéré jusqu'à présent 20 que le
monde fasse quelque chose nous savons
vous savez la France a la responsabilité
et l'obligation en tant qu'État parti
aux conventions internationales de
protéger et de d'agir pour mettre un
terme au crimes de guerre au crimes
contre l'humanité voire au génocide en
cours à Gaza comme partout dans le monde
et sans double standard en Ukraine comme
en Palestine se joue la défense des
principes fondamentaux du droit
international et l'avenir de l'Europe le
massacre de civil doit cesser quelle
mesure comptez-vous prendre pour faire
respecter le droit international et ses
résolutions vous engagez-vous à appuyer
et à faire appliquer les mesures
conservatoires demander à la CIJ vous
engagez-vous à saisir la Cour pénale
internationale comme les écologistes
vous y invitent par le dépôt d'une
résolution pour qualifier les faits tous
les faits et poursuivre les auteurs de
crimes comptez-vous décider l'embargo
sur les ventes d'armes à Israël enfin
Monsieur le Ministre qu comptez-vous
connaître l'état palestinien comme voté
par notre Parlement et soutenir
l'Espagne dans cette demande auprès de
l'Union
[Applaudissements]
européenne pour vous répondre la parole
est à la monsieur le ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
monsieur Stéphane séjourné à qui je
souhaite la bienvenue dans cet hémicycle
merci beaucoup monsieur monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice je veux
d'abord rappeler peut-être la la
solidarité de la France avec Israël
suite à à l'attaque terroriste de lundi
elle a fait au moins un mort 17 blessés
parmi lesquels deux de nos compatriotes
deux Français rien ne serait justifié le
terrorisme rien et je veux également
avoir une pensée pour tous les otages et
nos 41 compatriotes assassinés le 7
octobre nous leur rendrons hommage le 7
février prochain comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République hier
s'agissant de la situation à Gaza elle
s'aggrave de façon
dramatique dans cette guerre l'action de
la France se fonde sur trois piliers
fixés par le Président de la République
le volet sécuritaire vous l'avez dit
avec une lutte contre le terrorisme qui
passe par l'adoption prochaine d'un
régime de sanction européenne contre le
Hamas dès lundi notamment au Conseil des
affaires étrangères humanitaire ensuite
avec le respect du droit international
avec un cess le feu dur rame nécessaire
pour permettre l'acheminement de l'aide
la France a a d'ors et déjà déployé 1000
tonnes de nourriture et d'équipement et
100 millions d'euros pour les
populations palestiniennes et enfin
Madame la la sénatrice politique en vue
de retracer les perspectives de deux
états ce sujet sera d'ailleurs au cœur
de la réunion du Conseil de sécurité que
je présiderai le mardi 23 janvier à New
York
enfin il nous faut éviter l'escalade
régionale la France œuvre en ce sens au
Liban en mer Rouge et bien sûr en
sjordanie alors vous l'avez vu réponse
sécuritaire humanitaire politique
réponse nationale et réponse européenne
et internationale ce qui se joue au
prochorient est trop est trop important
pour être ignoré par notre pays il faut
éviter évidemment le pire merci
merci la parole est maintenant au
président François Noël buffet pour le
groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains voilà le micro est branché
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à vous Monsieur le Premier
Ministre à l'occasion des discussion sur
le texte immigration une partie du débat
s noué autour de l'aide médicale
d'État pendant ce débat le gouvernement
avait demandé à monsieurs Évin et
stéphanini de rendre un rapport ce qui a
été fait et puis sous la plume de votre
prédécesseur madame le Premier ministre
le 18 décembre dernier engagement a été
pris par le gouvernement de proposer
déposer un projet de loi en ce début
d'année 2024 pour aborder cette
thématique ma question enfin exactement
hier devant l'Assemblée nationale vous
avez confirmé monsieur le Premier
ministre
que cette démarche serait faite et donc
ma question est très très simple
euh allez-vous d'abord déposer ce projet
de loi sur la base simplement du rapport
déposé par Monsieur stéphanini et Evin
ou allez-vous ouvrir préalablement la
discussion avec le Parlement et
singulièrement avec le Sénat et si oui
finalement quand et comment allez-vous
procéder pour que nous continuions
d'avancer sereinement je le rit
sereinement sur ce texte merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur le Premier
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le Président buffet à
l'occasion des débats sur le projet de
loi immigration je n'étais pas dans les
fonctions que j'occupe aujourd'hui
j'étais membre du gouvernement et j'ai
pu évidemment observer ces débats j'ai
bien vu que la question de l'aide
médicale d'État a fait l'objet de
questions de discussion
légitime je le dis il n'est pas
illégitime de s'interroger sur toute ou
partie de nos dispositif public et de
notre modèle social c'est aussi pour ça
que nous sommes élus ou que nous sommes
nommés au gouvernement c'est pour
rinroger en permanence notre modèle et
je le dis l'aide médicale médicale
d'État a fait l'objet de questionnement
de de réinterrogation et d'évolution
sous des majorités de gauche comme des
majorités de droite et comme des
majorités comme celles qui nous
rassemble
autour du président de la République
j'ai le souvenir qu'en 2014 c'est un
souvenir vous l'imaginez assez proche
que à l'époque le gouvernement et la
ministre de l'époque Marisol Touren déjà
avait posé un certain nombre de
questions notamment sur les filières qui
abusaient de ce dispositif et que des
évolutions étai intervenu dans des
débats parlementaires et dans le
précédent mandat dans le précédent
quinquena il y a eu aussi des évolutions
sur la question du palier de soins de
manière je dois le dire assez
dépassionné et c'est ça la logique qui
doit je crois nous animer c'est regarder
les dispositifs tels qu'ils sont et
regarder comment nous pouvons les
améliorer et c'est en ce sens qui a été
confié vous l'avez rappelé une mission à
claud vin et Patrick stéphanini qui ont
travaillé je crois dans cet état
d'esprit là et je pense qu'il est
important de rappeler il a été rendu
public que le rapport indique d'abord
que l'aide médicale d'État est un
dispositif utile globalement maîtrisé je
crois que c'est les termes qui sont
employés et qui ne constituent pas en
tant que tel je fais attention aux mots
que j'utilise un levier d'incitation à
lui seul à l'immigration pour autant
est-ce que cela éteint toutes les
questions non et d'ailleurs le rapport
lui-même vous l'avez dit fait plusieurs
recommandations plusieurs propositions
qui me semblent assez intéressante et
légitime à partir de là comment on
avance vous le savez la première
ministre a adressé un courrier et
d'ailleurs président du Sénat m' aussi
interrogé sur les suites que j'entendais
donner à cet engagement la première
ministre s'engageant a donné une suite à
ce rapport par des mesures
réglementaires ou législatives hier j'ai
été interrogé à l'Assemblée nationale
vous l'avez rappelé sur les suites que
nous allions donner et surtout sur le
fait de savoir si je me considérais
engagé par la lettre de ma prédécesseur
ellisabeth borne j'ai répondu
qu'évidemment je respecterai
l'engagement qui a été pris par la
première ministre ensuite comment est-ce
qu'on va le faire c'est ça votre
question sur ce sujet-là je vous demande
de patienter quelques jour ou semaine
nous sommes vous le savez dans
l'installation du nouveau gouvernement
je dois en échanger évidemment avec le
ministre de l'intérieur avec la ministre
du Travail des solidarités et de la
santé et vous l'avez noté tout à l'heure
je présenterai ma déclaration de
politique générale le 30 janvier je
viendrai par ailleurs spécifiquement au
Sénat pour échanger sur tous les sujets
également donc l'engagement sera tenu
évidemment nous donnerons une suite à ce
rapport sur les modalité sur le
calendrier je reviendrai vers vous très
prochainement après avoir travaillé avec
mon gouvernement sur les suites que nous
donnerons
merci monsieur le Président
buffet merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pour cette réponse vous avez
dit il y a quelques jours que vous étiez
un adepte du constat de vérité c'est au
moins une conviction que nous avons en
commun dans ces conditions-l le Sénat en
tous les cas la majorité sénatoriale et
le groupe que je repr lequel je
m'exprime cet après-midi est prêt à un
travail approfondi sur ce sujet-là en
rappelant deux choses la première chose
c'est que le principe du soin pour les
personnes susceptibles bénéficiaires de
laame n'est pas remis en cause et la
deuxième chose c'est que notre volonté
c'est de maîtriser le dispositif et de
le contrôler de façon à être efficace
quant à son rôle qui lui est défini et
qu'il ne soit pas dévoyé de l'objet qui
lui a été promis
merci
merci la parole est àre collègue Nicole
Duranton pour le gros du rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères dans le contexte de
la guerre entre Israël et le Hamas la
tension est montée en mer Rouge ces
dernières semaine avec des attaques des
outils visant le trafic maritime en
solidarité avec la bande de Gaza cette
voie stratégique qui relie la
Méditerranée à l'océan Indien est
cruciale pour le commerce mondial avec
20000 navir la traversant chaque année
depuis mi-octobre cette route
commerciale est menacée par les outil
des rebelles yéménite membre d'une
organisation soutenue par l'Iran voulant
interdire le passage au navire des pays
qu'ils estiment être proche d'Israël
cette milice yéminite a rejoint la
coalition informelle appelée axe de la
résistance réunissant notamment l'Iran
le Hamas et le Hezbollah contre l'État
d'Israël cette coalition fait planer le
spectre d'un conflit
généralisé la France fait partie de la
coalition internationale assurant la
sécurité en mer Rouge en décembre
dernier la frégate langdoc en mission en
mer Rouge patrouillant dans la zone a
abattu en légitime défense des drones se
dirigeant vers elle ces attaques outil
dissuadent les navires commerciaux
d'emprunter la mer Rouge il se détourne
du canal de sueze optant pour le Cap de
Bonne Espérance
cette route alternative rallonge
considérablement leur trajet ce qui
résulte en une hausse du tarif des
transports ces attaques menacent la
libre circulation du commerce et violent
le droit international pour la France la
liberté de navigation en mer Rouge et
d'une importance cruciale pour ses
intérêts ne serait-ce que pour assurer
les liaisons maritimes avec ces
territoires de l'océan Indien Mayotte et
la Réunion cette situation
aggrave l'inflation sur le importations
la crise en mer Rouge n'est pas qu'un
danger sur le plan sécuritaire c'est
aussi un danger commercial avec des
répercussions qui entraîne une pression
inflationniste sur la France l'Europe et
qui pénalise l'économie mondiale
monsieur le ministre face à cette double
menace sécuritaire et commerciale en mer
Rouge quelle mesure envisagez-vous pour
protéger les intérêts commerciaux et
économiques de la
France pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
sé journé merci Monsieur monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice Nicole
Duranton oui les outil menace la
sécurité maritime et le commerce
international en mer Rouge ces attaques
sont une atteinque à nos intérêts
nationaux et européens un navire CMA CGM
et la frégate longdoc ont d'ailleurs été
directement ciblé plusieurs compagnies
maritimes vous l'avez dit vous-même sont
contraints de contourner C zone ces
attaques sont aussi une violation
évidente du droit international la
résolution adoptée le 10 janvier par le
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
les condamne et rappelle le droit des
États à se défendre contre ces menaces
face à ces menaces la France agit en
détruisant directement les drones
dirigés contre des navires qui sont
civils ou qu'ils soient militaire dans
ce contexte les États-Unis ont fait le
choix d'une opération militaire sur les
territoires contrôlés par les outils la
France n'a pas souhaité prendre part à
ces opérations à ce stade nous nous
contentons de mener une action en mer et
en total une autonomie d'ailleurs
parfaite en coordination avec nos alliés
nous étudions d'ailleurs les moyens de
renforcer la présence européenne en mer
Rouge voilà notre approche madame la
sénatrice fermeté dans le cadre
collectif et en même temps si je peux me
permettre des escalades par le dialogue
l'escalade est la est de la seule
responsabilité aujourd'hui des outils et
notre responsabilité et d'éviter un
embrasement supplémentaire dans la
région
merci
merci la parole est maintenant au
président Claude muré par le groupe Les
Indépendants
républ après vous avoir félicité
Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour votre
nomination tion je voudrais évoquer les
propos de votre ministre des Affaires
étrangères à Kiev déclarant que l'aide à
l'Ukraine restera une priorité il faut
maintenant tenir cette promesse la
situation est devenue critique les
crimes de guerre du boucher du kremelin
infligent chaque jour un atroce supplice
à la population civile d'Ukraine les
Ukrainiens qui ont brillamment
contre-attaqué à carkiv et Kerson en
2022 sont aujourd'hui en position de
faiblesse parce que depuis le début le
soutien des démocraties peut résumé par
la formule trop peu trop tard si nous
avions livré à temps les chars les
missiles les batteries antiaériennes
l'armées russes n'aurait pu reconstituer
ses défenses et faire échouer la
contre-offensive de 2023 nous sommes en
train de renouveler cette erreur depuis
des mois zelensk attend les 60 milliards
de dollars de Washington bloqués par les
trumpistes au Congrès et les 50
milliards d'euros de l'Europe paralysé
par ces 5è colonnes Orban le collabo en
Hongrie Le Pen et mélenchant les chien
chien à leur Poutine en France et tant
d'autres ailleurs nos tergiversation
mettent l'Ukraine en grand danger je
pèse mes mots une défaite serait celle
de l'Europe toute entière un formidable
stimulant pour la Chine face à Taïwan
pour le Docteur Folamour de Corée du
Nord pour les Morlas iraniens tueurs de
femmes au Moyen-Orient il serait
impensable que le prochain Conseil
européen du 1er février ne déjoue pas
les manœuvres d'Orban le corrompu et ne
débloque pas la totalité de l'aide
promise à l'Ukraine je vous demande
aujourd'hui l'engagement formel y
parvenir et de soutenir sans restriction
le fond d'investissement européen en
défense de 100 milliards proposé par le
commissaire français Thierry Breton en
ce début de mandat vous vous dites sans
doute monsieur le Premier ministre que
vous serez jugé sur vos résultats dans
notre pays et c'est exact mais à
l'échelle de l'histoire votre
gouvernement et tous les gouvernements
de l'Europe seront jugés à l'ône de la
victoire ou de la défaite des
démocraties en Ukraine face à
l'international reconstitué des
dictateurs
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur le Premier
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le Président maluret
il y a près de 2 ans en dépit de toutes
les règles de droit international et de
tous ses engagements la Russie a agressé
l'Ukraine c'est une attaque cynique
meurtrière avec des frappes aériennes
répétées qui visent explicitement les
civils ce qui est en jeu dans ce conflit
et je vous remercie de l'avoir rappelé
aussi clairement c'est la liberté c'est
la démocratie et c'est l'avenir de notre
continent la Russie espère que l'Ukraine
cèdera et que ses soutiens se lasseront
et je le dis de manière très claire en
tant que chef du gouvernement le
président de la République l'a rappelé
hier la Russie se trompe comme l'a
rappelé le président de la République
nous ne faiblirons pas et nous ne
faiblirons jamais notre détermination
est intacte et je le réaffirme ici
devant vous le ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères s'est rendu à
Kief vous le savez c'était son premier
déplacement après sa nomination
permettez-moi pour la première fois en
tant que Premier ministre au nom du
gouvernement et en votre nom à tous j'en
suis sûr de dire mon admiration pour le
peuple ukrainien et de saluer son
courage
exceptionnel monsieur le Président
maluret vous avez évoqué notre soutien à
l'Ukraine je le disais à l'instant il ne
faiblira pas le président de la
République a annoncé hier la livraison
de nouveaux missiles de longue portée et
de centaines de bombes ce sont des
armements attendus par les ukrainiens et
qui seront déterminant sur le terrain en
parallèle nous continuons à former des
militaires ukrainiens comme nous l'avons
fait depuis le début du conflit pour
répondre à leurs besoins nous
poursuivrons donc notre soutien
militaire en concertation avec nos
partenaires j'ajoute que notre soutien
humanitaire continue lui aussi pour
répondre aux besoins les plus immédiats
du peuple ukrainien notamment en matière
d'éducation et de santé pour réussir la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs est
essentielle je pense évidemment à l'état
je pense aux collectivités locales don
je veux saluer aussi engagement
remarquable beaucoup interviennent
évidemment en solidarité avec les
Ukrainiens je pense aussi aux acteurs
privés engagés en soutien de l'économie
ukrainienne ou déjà évidemment pour la
reconstruction notre soutien de long
terme à l'Ukraine civile comme militaire
sera inscrit dans l'accord bilatéral de
sécurité que le Président de la
République signera avec le président
Zelenski lors de son déplacement à kieev
en février ce soutien de la France le
président de la République aura
l'occasion de le réaffirmer vendredi à
cherbour en adressant ses vœux à nos
armées j'ajoute et vous l'avez abordé
aussi que la France porte également la
mobilisation en faveur de l'Ukraine au
niveau européen nous sommes déterminés à
obtenir un accord sur la facilité
Ukraine au Conseil européen
extraordinaire du 1er février déterminé
concrètement cette facilité doit
permettre à l'Ukraine de faire face à
ses besoins de financement immédiat et
de mener les investissements essentiels
pour se construire et se moderniser
l'Union européenne est également
déterminée à poursuivre son soutien
militaire à l'Ukraine le Conseil
européen de décembre dernier ainsi
demandé que s'intensifie les travaux sur
la réforme de la facilité européenne
pour la paix en s'en prenant à l'Ukraine
la Russie a attaqué nos valeurs la
Russie a remis en cause la démocratie et
la liberté nous nous tiendrons au côté
de l'Ukraine et du peuple ukrainien nous
nous tiendrons toujours au côté de nos
valeurs c'est une une de nos priorités
elle le reste je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Nathalie de l'intre pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Agriculture mes chers
collègues il y a 4 ans jour pour jour
lors de notre séance des questions au
Gouvernement notre collègue Muriel
Jourda interroger le ministre de
l'Agriculture de l'époque Didier
Guillaume sur la manière dont il
comptait venir en aide aux
austriculteurs alors durablement touchés
par des pollutions de l'eau au
neurovirus lors des fêtes de fin d'année
de 2019 Madame Élisabeth borne alors
ministre de la transition écologique
rappelit que dans le cadre du 11e
programme d'intervention des agences de
l'eau 3,6 milliards d'euros d'aide
serait accordé au titre du traitement
des EAU usées comment et où ces fonds
ont-ils été employés car force de
constater que les mêmes causes ont
produit les mêmes effets on témoigne
l'interdiction de la vente d'huttre du
bassin d'Arcachon prise par arrêté
préfectoral le 27 décembre dernier en
raison de la contamination de la
production au
neurovirus le préfet a réuni autour de
lui les collectivités et les
établissements publics compétents dans
la gestion des eaux usées et des eaux
pluviales sur le bassin versant il a
promis d'accélérer les programmes
d'investissement pour apporter des
réponses à moyen et long terme il y a
quelques jours le ministre Christophe
Béchu toujours là m'indiquait suite à un
courrier que je lui avais adressé que
l'État pourrait intervenir sur des aides
à l'investissement sauf qu'il n'est pas
pour leur question d'investir mais il
est question pour ces austriculteurs de
survivre la fermeture pour 28 jours de
la totalité de la zone de production du
bassin d'Arcachon a entraîné 5 millions
d'euros de pertes sèches et la crainte
de perdre la confiance des consommateurs
aussi au côté des aides aux
collectivités à annoncer comment
allez-vous aider directement monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture nos
austriculteurs et nos austriicultrices
et serez-vous adjoint d'un ministre
dédié à la mer tant les enjeux en la
matière sont vastes
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur Marc
fenau vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice de lâre vous avez raison c'est
un sujet récurrent qui est celui des
difficultés é lié notamment au
traitement des eaux usées c'est parce
qu'on sait que c'est le la cause
principale et vous l'avez rappelé à
l'essue d'épisodes plus viométrique
intense de débordement de stations
d'épuration et des opérations délestage
sur les
réseaux réseau de d'eau pluviale qui
était saturé ont conduit à la
propagation du neurovirus qui produit
des infections humaines de type
gastro-entérique de nature aigu ce qui
justifie des mesures de protection qui
ont été prises d'ailleurs par la
Direction Générale de l'Alimentation ces
interdictions temporaires sont destinées
la protéger la santé de des
consommateurs ce qui reste et je crois
que les austriculteurs l'ont dit avec
grande responsabilité la priorité
évidemment absolue dans ces cas-là mais
elles ne sont pas lié du tout ces
difficultés là qu' la qualité du travail
des austriculteurs vous l'avez rappelé
d'une certaine façon si les coquillages
contaminés peuvent à nouveau être
commercialisés une fois le virus éteint
à la suite d'un épisode de filtration
dans des eaux saines le préjudu
économique et le préjudu d'image
c'est-à-dire le préjudice médiatique est
important une nouvelle fois puisque les
producteurs ne sont en rien responsables
la possibilité de mobiliser des mesures
de soutien ça avait été dit et ça a été
dit par Hervé Berville de mobiliser des
mesures de soutien é à l'étude certaines
ayant déjà été activé par le passé on
verra s'il y en a pas d'autres à
mobiliser je pense à des exonération de
la redavance domaniale et les choses
qu'on peut faire en matière fiscale ou
en matière de charge sociale nous le
verrons avec le ministre de l'économie
et des finances nous le verrons aussi
sur les sujets des collectivités locales
avec Christophe Béchu vous l'avez vous
l'avez cité en effet sur ces sujets là
il convient de souligner que le d'abord
le plein exercice du principe de
pollueur payeur et je suis un élu local
qui sait à quelle fois par parfois c'est
difficile de développer des projets mais
là il y a une responsabilité pollueur
payur deuxième élément c'est d'accélérer
sur les investissements ça n'a sans
doute que trop tardé il faut qu'on
accompagne les collectivités c'est sans
doute pas aussi simple que cela et c'est
le travail que vous avez nommé qu'on va
accélérer avec la préfecture de ces
zones les préfectures parce qu' il n'y a
pas que dans votre département
malheureusement que ça s'est développé
pour avancer accélér indemniser dans le
court terme et accélérer les process
d'investissement dans le moyen et long
terme
merci la parole est maintenant au
président Patrick canner pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicain monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre dans un
exercice assumé
d'autosatisfaction le président Macron
hier m'a rassuré notre pays va bien
l'ascenseur sociale fonctionne et nos
services publics ont les moyens de
remplir leur mission j'ai sans doute
étit distrait car pour moi la réalité
était toute autre dans ma réalité
l'école publique est fragilisée par des
professeurs non remplacés des abusés
l'hôpital public s'effondre j'ai en tête
l'exemple tristement emblématique de la
maternité Jeane de Flandre à Lille qui
transfère une partie de ses patientes et
de leurs bébés en Belgique dans ma
réalité la France compte désormais près
de 5 million de pauvres et la classe
moyenne a de plus en plus de mal à
joindre les debouts le déclassement
social frappe de plus en plus nos
concitoyens dans ma réalité le logement
traverse une crise d'une ampleur inédite
depuis 30 ans sans disposer à ce stade
d'un ministre de plein exercice monsieur
le Premier ministre il faut ouvrir les
yeux voilà l'état de la France et vous
en êtes comptable les propos du
président de la République traduisent sa
déconnexion avec le quotidien des
Français pour lui c'est la moralisation
et l'ordre pour les citoyens la la
dérégulation et le désordre pour les
intérêts financiers ce n'est pas
l'optimisme dont il a fait preuve hier
soir il cultive une amnésie politicienne
pour conserver ce mauvais cap fixé il y
a bientôt 7 ans les français eux n'ont
rien oublié ni l'injuste réforme des
retraites ni la stigmatisation des
chômeurs ni la xénophobie rempante de la
loi immigration Monsieur le Premier
Ministre aurez-vous la lucidité de poser
ce constat aurez-vous l'audace d'en
tirer toutes les
conséquences pour vous répondre la
parole est au Premier
[Applaudissements]
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateur monsieur le Président canner
bon manifestement nous n'avons pas
assisté à la même conférence de presse
en tout cas j'y étais avec mon
gouvernement et je crois que les
Français qui nombreux ont assisté à
cette conférence de presse par la
télévision au contraire au contraire
entendu un président de la République
lucide sur les difficultés de notre pays
et sur les défis que nous avons à
relever est-ce que la lucidité est-ce
que la lucidité sur ces difficultés doit
nous empêcher
de reconnaître et de mettre en avant un
certain nombre de progrès qui sont
intervenus ces dernières années dans
notre pays moi je ne crois
pas je pense que sur la question du
chômage avec un taux de chômage aussi
bas que nous ne l'avions pas connu
depuis un certain nombre d'années dans
notre pays quand même on peut quand même
se dire que c'est un progrès mais pas un
progrès pour le gouvernement pas un
progrès pour le président de la
République un progrès pour ces millions
de Français qui ont pu retrouver un
emploi quand on voit le décollage de
l'apprentissage dans notre pays avec
bientôt 1 million de jeunes qui chaque
année sont en apprentissage on peut se
dire que c'est un progrès pas pour le
gouvernement pas pour le président de la
République mais avant tout pour tous ces
jeunes qui vont pouvoir trouver leur
voie grâce à
l'apprentissage quand on voit un certain
nombre de droits qui ont été ouvert dans
notre pays ces dernières années à
l'initiative du Président de la
République et de la majorité je pense
par exemple à l'ouverture de la PMA pour
toutes les femmes on peut se dire qu'il
y a eu un progrès pas pour le
gouvernement le président de la
République mais pour toutes ces femmes
qui vont pouvoir s'engager dans un
projet familial je pourrais multiplier
un certain nombre d'exemples est-ce que
ça me rend aveugle ou sour aux
difficultés que traversent les Français
et à la situation du pays la réponse est
non et je crois l'avoir dit dès ma prise
de fonction à Matignon lors de la
passation de pouvoir je suis lucide sur
les difficultés sur les angoisses sur
les inquiétudes sur les doutes les
colère de beaucoup de français et même
sur les Français qui n'expriment pas de
colère tout simplement parce qu'il end
plus rien j'en suis conscient je sais
que tous ces Français qui tous les jours
vont travailler qui sont toujours au
rendez-vous de leur responsabilité qui
ont toujours le sentiment d'être
au-dessus de ce qu'il faut pour être
accompagné par la solidarité nationale
et en dessous de ce qu'il faut pour
pouvoir s'en sortir tout seul ils
attendent beaucoup de nous je suis
conscient que les Français attendent
évidemment beaucoup en matière de santé
d'accès aux soins et d'hôpital et je le
dis monsieur le Président canner c'est s
de tous j'ai été membre du Parti
socialiste j'ai travaillé auprès de la
ministre des Affaires sociales et de la
santé monsieur le Président canner je le
dis les budgets et l'investissement qui
ont été dédiés à l'hôpital public depuis
2017 à travers le segure de la santé
mais pas seulement on en aurait rêvé
dans les précédentes majorités on en
aurait rêvé dans les précédentes
majorités c'est ça la réalité ça n'étit
pas les arbitrages qui étaient rendus à
l'époque financier il y a eu un choix
qui a été fait résolu de soutenir
l'hôpital mais évidemment l'argent ne
suffit pas et ce qu'il faut c'est que
poursuivre la transformation poursuivre
un travail sur les coopérations pour
l'accès aux soins de tous les Français
et c'est le mandat de Catherine Vautrin
évidemment que sur la question de
l'école il y a de nombreux défis encore
à relever et j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire ces derniers mois quand j'occupais
le poste de ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse je pense que
j'ai montré que j'étais capable de
porter un constat lucide sur les
difficultés de notre école et aussi de
prendre un certain nombre de premières
décisions assez ferm et assez radical
sur la question de la laïcité à l'école
qui ne doit jamais souffrir d'aucune
contestation et qui doit être en tout
lieu de notre territoire respecté j'ai
pris cette décision extrêmement claire
dès ma prise de fonction sur la remise
de l'excellence et de l'exigence à tous
les niveaux à l'école parce qu'on ne
peut pas accepter que pour certains
l'école soit devenue une forme de tapis
roulant sur lequel on se pose et on
glisse de classe en classe sans vérifier
si on a le niveau pour passer dans la
classe supérieure
c'est pour l'égalité des chances qu'on
remet de l'exigence et de l'excellence à
tous les niveaux et c'est le mandat de
la ministre qui poursuivra évidemment
cette action et déclinera le choc des
savoirs que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'annoncer oui je suis lucide aussi sur
les difficultés en matière de sécurité
pour nos concitoyens lucide sur le fait
que nous avons recruté 14000 postes de
policiers et de gendarmes
supplémentaires depuis 2017 que nous
avons investi comme jamais dans la
justice avec un garde des saut
particulièrement tonique pour obtenir
des budgets supplémentaires pour son
ministère j'ai pu le le voir en tant que
ministre des comptes publics et oui là
aussi il y a des enjeux de
transformation à poursuivre pour que le
service public de la justice soit
toujours au rendez-vous des Français
enfin je suis lucide aussi sur ce qui
nous reste à accomplir pour la
transition écologique et la protection
de la planète je suis Premier ministre
et je suis aussi en charge de la
planification écologique de notre pays
comme ma prédécesseur et oui j'aurais à
cœur d'appliquer même d'accélérer avec
mes ministres sur la feuille de route
présentée par le Président de la
République sur la planification qui nous
place là aussi comme un pays moteur en
matière d'ambition de transition
écologique j'entends les critiques et
les questions qui sont posées mais
j'attends qu'on me montre un pays de
l'Union européenne qui s'engage autant
que nous qui a réussi à réduire de 4 %
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre
comme nous l'avons fait l'an dernier
quel pays a réussi à faire pareil en
dans l'Union européenne un pays qui a le
niveau d'émission de CO2 par unité de
production aussi faible que le nôtre en
France dans les pays comparables qu'on
me le présente je vais pas faire ici ma
déclaration de politique générale mais
en tout cas vous voyez que j'avais des
choses à vous dire
j'ai des choses sur le cœur et je suis
sûr que nous aurons de très beaux débats
ici tous ensemble au Sénat monsieur le
Président
canner monsieur le Premier ministre je
ne doute pas de votre sincérité
simplement je vous le dis comme je le
pense changer de premier violon ne
change pas la
partition et quand le président de la
République vous qualifie de soldat de
l'an 2 lors du premier Conseil des
ministres situé à côté de son bureau à
l'Élysée je ne voudrais pas que ces
soldats de l' 2 de la République qui ont
sauvé la République se transformment
demain en cavalier de l'apocalypse ceux
qui permettront que l'extrême droite
puisse s'installer dans ce pays et votre
politique malheureusement est en train
d'y
concourir la parole est à notre collègue
Max Brisson pour le groupe les
républicain merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre deéducation nationale de la
jeunesse des sports et des Jeux
olympiques et
paralympiques j'espère madame n'avoir
oublié aucune de vos fonctions lors de
la passation rue de grenis le vendredi
dernier le Premier ministre affirmé
l'école sera la mère des batailles de
mon gouvernement le président l'a
confirmé hier j'ai donc trois questions
à vous poser à la lumière de votre large
portefeuille concrètement comment
comptez-vous conseiller concilier de
manière efficace et permanente la
bataille de la refondation de l'école et
en même temps le défi de l'organisation
des Jeux de Paris dans cette même dans
cette MRE des batailles quelle image du
professeur entendez-vous porter dans la
société quelle est votre vision de son
rôle de sa place de son autorité dans
cette mer des batailles quel rôle et
quel place entendez-vous donner à
l'enseignement privé sous contrat et
hors
contrat
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame oua Castera madame la ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Brisson en réunissant les
champs de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports dans notre
contexte olympique et paralympique vous
n'avez rien oublié le président de la
République et le Premier ministre m'ont
confié un continuum de responsabilité
aux synergies qui sont en effet
nombreuses mais au cœur de ce continuum
il y a une ambition le réarmement
civique de notre jeunesse et il y a un
trésor c'est l'école alors pour la
servir je m'appuierai sur trois pilier
d'abord restaurer l'exigence à travers
le choc des savoirs impulsés par Gabriel
Atal et à travers la réaffirmation de
l'autorité de nos professeurs sur la vie
de classe sur leur enseignement sur les
décisions de redoublement et sur les
notations deuxième pilier renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers de
l'enseignement en réinventant la
formation initiale des enseignants en
repensant leur formation continue en
continuant d'améliorer l'organisation et
les remplacements de courte durée en
poursuivant les réformes engagées pour
la revalorisation des carrières et des
conditions de travail cell des
enseignants mais aussi d'autres
catégories de personnel comme les
infirmières scolaires les assistants
sociaux et les aesh troisème pilier
construire plus que jamais dans la
France des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques une école de
l'épanouissement républicain où la peur
et le harcèlement n'ont plus leur place
une école dans laquelle tous les élèves
s'approprient les valeurs de la
République avec l'instruction civique le
respect de la laïcité et l'engagement à
travers le SNU une école inclusive
monsieur le sénateur et attentive au
bien-être et à la santé de tous nos
enfants une école ouverte sur la société
avec la découverte des métiers au
collège les stages de seconde la
nouvelle carte des formations pour les
lycéens professionnels une école enfin
qui sait reconnaître les singularités de
nos enfants et faire grandir le leurs
talents notamment oui par le sport par
l'art et la culture une détermination
faire réussir la jeunesse faire réussir
toutes les écoles de notre pays je vous
remercie monsieur Brisson madame la
ministre moi je vais vous parler du
zigzag que le Président de la République
fait subir à notre école Jean-Michel
Blanquer parler laïcité autorité et
confiance avant de constater impuissant
une malgré l'avalanche de circulaire la
dégringola de notre école papend ensuite
passer par-dessus bord les principes
chers à son prédécesseur et son couvert
de mixité sociale a sappé les derniers
espaces d'excellence de notre école
Gabriel at l'enfer qui durant 5 mois et
20 jours nous avire une offre une ode
quotidienne à l'école dont nous
attendons toujours la traduction dans
les actes au lieu de de zigzag ne
serait-il pas temps de fixer un cap et
de s'y tenir dans la durée avec pour
valeur centrale la liberté l'autorité le
mérite l'excellence et la performance
tel est la merre des batailles à mener
mais avec un tel portefeuille madame la
ministre cette MRE des batailles sous le
poids de vos responsabilités ne
risque-t-elle pas plutôt de finir
noyer
merci la parole est à notre collègue
audre bellim pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre la réunion a connu pour
la première fois depuis 30 ans le
passage de l'œil d'un cyclone je profite
de ce moment pour exprimer ma solidarité
aux Mauriciens durement touché également
à l'heure où nous parlons le bilan
humain fait état de quatre décès sur le
plan matériel de nombreux réionnais sont
sinistrés les récoltes des agriculteurs
ont été fortement impactées par le
cyclone je salue l'action des élus
locaux qui ont ouvert dans des délais
contraints 158 centres d'hébergement
d'urgence pour les populations les plus
fragiles mais également l'action du
préfet du gouvernement vendredi devait
être annoncé la reconnaissance de l'état
de catastrophe naturelle comme demandé
par l'association des maires du
département de La Réunion que j'ai
soutenu pour l'instant la réunion a tenu
mais Béal n'est qu'un avertissement de
plus la prévention des risques et la
préparation face aux crises doivent être
renforcé à court terme se pose la
question de l'accompagnement des
collectivités par exemple à Saint-Denis
les dépenses post cyclone s'élèvent à 6
million d'euros et ce sans les travaux
sur le bâti à moyen terme se pose la
question de la résilience de notre
territoire de nombreux réonnais n'ont
plus accès à l'ctricité et donc plus
accès à l'eau non plus les budgets liés
au réseau de distribution d'électricité
sont-ils à la hauteur des besoins
comment se fait-il que les fils
électriques ne soient pas enterrés alors
que la Réunion est une terre de cyclone
ce ce n'est pas une surprise ce n'est
pas imprévisible une succession de
cellules de crise ne pourra pas faire
une politique se pose aussi la question
de notre lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique nous l'avons vu dans le pas
decalé nous le voyons aujourd'hui à la
Réunion les tempêtes et cyclones vont se
multiplier et s'aggraver qu'allez-vous
faire pour accélérer en matière de
transition énergétique alors même que le
ministère de plein exercice a été
supprimé la question n'est donc pas de
savoir ce qui a été fait mais bien ce
que vous allez faire merci pour vous
répondre la parole est à la ministre
déléguée chargé du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement madame prisia tevenau vous
avez la parole bienvenue merci monsieur
le président madame la sénatrice à mon
tour effectivement au nom du
gouvernement je me permets de saluer ici
la résilience et la force de capacité
d'engagement aussi bien des habitants de
l'île de la réunion mais également des
forces de secours de sécurité
effectivement également de nombreux
secouristes engagés auprès des
associations et des élus locaux il est
évident je me permets aussi de saluer
ici en solidarité les habitants de l'île
Maurice qui a également qui ont
également été frappés par ce cyclone
permettez-moi de de répondre très
rapidement mais avec précision aux
différents éléments importants que vous
avez interrogé l'alerte rouge a
effectivement été levée par le préfet
hier à 13h Heure locale à cette heure
les actions de reconnaissance se
poursuivent et les débléement des
voiries ont débuté les coupures
d'électricité d'eau et de réseaux
téléphoni fixes comme mobile ont été
importantes mais sont en cours de
réparation les principaux réseaux de
communication routière ont été réouverts
à la circulation seul le réseau
secondairire et la voie d'accès à silaos
à Siloas pardon doivent encore faire
l'objet de travaux de déblaement sur le
plan humain nous déplorons quatre
victimes
le président de la République a décidé
l'engagement de moyens nationaux ainsi
que des sapeurs pompiers des sapeurs
sauveteurs des gendarmes et les agents
d'enedit sont partis en renfort de
métropole mais également de Mayotte
l'aide de l'État va se poursuivre avec
une procédure accélérée de
reconnaissance de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle dont la Commission devrait se
réunir dès demain madame la sénatrice
avec l'appui du préfet l'ensemble des
dispositifs d'appui aux populations
exploitant du monde agricole ou
industriel touché par ce cyclone vont
être activés tel que le dispositif de
calimité agricole ou le fond d'aide
outreem par ailleurs vous soulevez un
point important c'est dans capacité
d'anticiper et de continuer à renforcer
nos capacités de travailler sur ces
enjeux climatiques qui sont de plus en
plus fréquents et forts bien évidemment
la France y prend toute sa part mais
également au niveau européen un groupe a
été mis en place pour travailler à ces
enjeux- là et notamment la France aura
une voix particulière au regard de sa
capacité à témoigner de de ces
territoires d'outrem
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Anne chin Larcher pour le
groupe les
républicains monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues monsieur le Premier
ministre en 2023 la France a compté
seulement 678000 naissances en 1 an
c'est une baisse de 7 % en 13 ans une
chute de 20 % ce che de la natalité est
destructeur pour notre économie et notre
système social il constitue une menace
existentielle pour notre pays puisque le
renouvellement des générations n'est
plus assuré le recours à une immigration
massive pour compenser ce déficit de
naissance serait une très grave erreur
cela risquerait de détruire la cohésion
nationale le nombre d'enfants désirés
par les familles reste largement
supérieur aux naissances la
responsabilité du gouvernement est
immense que s'est-il passé ces dernières
années le cocient familial a été renié
les allocations rabotées les coûts de
garde d'enfant augmenté la prestation
jeune enfant diminué et j'en passe c'est
une véritable guerre contre les familles
qui a été mené et nous en payons le prix
l'annonce d'un congé de naissance de 6
mois sans en connaître les moyens est
encore à côté de la plaque d'autant plus
qui entraînerait la suppression du congé
parental à l'actuelle de 2 ans ce qui
aggraverait les problèmes de garde
d'enfants pour de nombreuses familles
alors ma question est simple quelle est
votre politique
familiale la parole est à la ministre
délégué porte-parole du gouvernement
madame tevenau merci monsieur le
Président je me permets d'excuser
Catherine Vautrin qui est retenue en ce
m en ce moment même pardon à l'Assemblée
pour des débats madame la sénatrice
effectivement la France accuse cette
année une baisse de natalité sans
précédent les raisons sont multiples
quand le désir d'enfant est présent
baisse de la fertilité lié à l'arrivée
plus tardive du premier enfant
difficulté d'accès au mort de garde mais
également baisse de fertilité lié à des
facteurs exogènes des mesures ont d'ors
et déjà été annoncées et mises en œuvre
en 2023 allongement du congé paternité à
25 jours mise en place de l'entretien
prénatal et postnatal précoce
investissement massive dans la recherche
contre l'infertilité dans le cadre de
francerance l'infertilité qui d'ailleurs
je préfère ici aussi le rappeler n'est
pas simplement du fait des hommes des
femmes mais touche également les hommes
et il est important de le rappeler pour
pouvoir le traiter nous avons leevé par
ailleurs le tabou de l'endométriose qui
est la première cause d'infertilité
féminine et qui touche une femme sur 10
il faut aujourd'hui aller plus loin dans
l'accompagnement des parents ce sont
200000 solutions de garde nouvelles qui
doivent être trouvées d'ici la fin du
quinquena la nouvelle convention
d'objectif et de gestion qui lit l'État
à la CAF prévoit près de 6 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires consacrés à la
petite enfance d'ici 2027 nous allons
également accélérer la lutte contre la
pénurie de professionnels de la petite
enfance et renforcer l'attractivité des
métiers c'est l'enjeu des
revalorisations salariales annoncé que
nous allons mettre en œuvre en lien bien
évidemment avec les branches et les
communes enfin le président de la
République a annoncé hier la mise en
place d'un nouveau congé de naissance
plus court mieux rémunéré que le congé
parental actuel il permettra d'augmenter
le temps de présence auprès des enfants
sur les 1000 premiers jours de la vie
sans pénaliser les ménages sur le plan
financier et en rééquilibrant la charge
dans le couple je vous
remercie madame
chalarcher alors je m'adresse à ce
nouveau gouvernement arrêtez de dépenser
de l'argent public à coût de chèque et
de subvention bidon mais investissez
pour la petite enfance et le pouvoir
d'achat soutenez financièrement et
fiscalement toutes les familles faites
coexister congé parental court bien
rémunéré et congé long moins rémunéré
soutenz la création de places de crèche
et redonner un ministère à la famille ce
sont les familles d'aujourd'hui qui
prépare la France de demain il faut leur
redonner espoir et confiance agitez vite
agissez vite et fort où notre pays
disparaîtra la parole est maintenant à
la présidente Sylvie vermeiller pour le
groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
au matin de Noël puis du Nouvel An
Gabriel Brémont maèire desclan nenon
dans le Jura découvre des tags partout
dans le village et sur les murs de sa
mairie sal travelot le maire s'envoie
en l'air nique ta mère le maire Gabriel
en portejartel bremmont T de con des
injures homophobes attaque personnelle
d'une violence inouï qui choque encore
tout un village et bien au-delà du Jura
Gabriel Brémont est un maire sans
histoire apprécié de ses administrés il
est solide il a déposé plainte et fait
face mais comment les témoignages de
sympathie de ses administrés lui
apportent un réconfort salutaire ainsi
que ceux des maires de toute la France
qui témoigne de la solidarité des
membres de cette grande famille
républicaine qui l'a choisi de servir et
qui n'en finit pas d'être maltraité 2600
agressions l'an passé 50 % de plus qu'il
y a 2 ans et malgré les indignations les
textes votés la dérive est implacable
insupportable monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez rappelé à Dijon le
weekend dernier nous sommes un
gouvernement qui va continuer d'agir
contre les discriminations contre
l'homophobie et en faveur des droits de
tous voyez-vous que les auteurs de ces
attaques démontre que leurs auteurs
n'ont ni peur des forces de l'ordre ni
peur de la justice notre République ne
sait pas protéger ses maires monsieur le
ministre qu'allez-vous changer pour
qu'il soit
respecté pour vous répondre à la parole
et à monsieur Éric dupomti garde des
saut ministre de la
Justice merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice Sylvie Vermeillet je pense
que nous sommes tous à cet instant Unis
par la même indignation par la même
colère par la même
révolte face à cette agression
doublement
infemme doublement parce que c'est une
agression homophobe et parce qu'elle
vise un
élu je dois dire à cet instant au maire
des clan n non tout le soutien du
gouvernement auquel
j'appartiens
vous le savez madame la sénatrice dès
mon arrivée à la Chancellerie j'ai pris
un certain nombre de circulaires
clair pour demander expressément à tous
les procureurs de notre pays une réponse
systématique une réponse ferme une
réponse
rapide le budget que vous avez voté les
trois budgets que le Sénat a voté et je
l' merci nous permettent désormais
d'envoyer des personnels supplémentaires
magistrat greffiers contractuel devenu
attaché de justice et à Besançon une
cour d'appel dont je sais madame la
sénatrice qu'elle vous est chère c'est
58 de ces personnels qui vont arriver
j'ai par ailleurs demandé à tous les
procureurs de ce pays de dire aux élus
quelles étent l'issue de la plainte
qu'ils ont déposé nous avons ont mis en
place par ailleurs grâce au contractuel
devenu attachés de justice un lien qui
doit être un lien privilégié entre les
élus locaux et les parquets et pour vous
rassurer totalement même si bien sûr on
déplore le nombre d'agressions qui
existe je veux vous donner quelques
chiffres si vous m'y autorisez en 2022
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs le taux
de réponse pénal des infractions
commises contre les élus s'élève à 98 %.
àv égale pour des faits de violence le
taux prononcé d'un emprisonnement ferme
et de 51 % lorsque la victime est un élu
25 % lorsque la victime n'est pas un élu
et enfin le taux de déferment est c fois
plus élevé le taux de mandat de dépôt
quatre fois plus élevé quand la victime
est un élu soyez assurés madame la
sénatrice mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs que le combat continue
que nos efforts dans la défense des élus
est total bien évidemment comme notre
engagement parce que s'attaquer à un élu
c'est s'attaquer à la
République madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur le gardesso
pour vos propos mais je crois que tous
ici nous constatons encore énormément de
plaintes qui sont classées sans suite
donc effectivement la clé c'est la
fermeté et la clé c'est la sanction en
face de toute agression merci très
bien la parole est à notre collègue
Laurence müerbrown pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le Conseil d'analyse économique rattaché
au Premier ministre a révélé la semaine
dernière que l'étiquette énergie des
logements de A à G qui définit
aujourd'hui leurs valeurs et les
autorisent ou non à être loué repose en
réalité sur des calculs purement
théorique et sur une modélisation très
approximative ainsi le fameux diagnostic
de performance énergétique DPE
transformé en quête du Graal climatique
pour lequel l'État investit des
milliards ne reflète pas la consommation
réel des logements ni les prétendus
gains énergétiques attendus or c'est
bien lui qui agg grave aujourd'hui une
crise du logement sans précédent
notamment pour les locataires et les
propriétaires les plus modestes depuis
le 1er janvier 2023 tous les logements
classés G+ sont interdits à la loocation
et cette décision repose sur un
algorithme biaisé que dites-vous
monsieur le ministre aux propriétaires
et aux locataires qui en font déjà les
frais si on persiste dans les des
échéances annoncé 11 millions de
logements classés F G vont être
interdits à la location dans les 10 10
années à venir sans véritable raison une
fois de plus cette machine à exclure
retombera sur les mers eux-mêmes
dépasser par la pénurie des logements et
les contra les contraintes liées à la
construction monsieur le ministre
qu'allez-vous faire pour supprimer et
remplacer cet outil défaillant qui
paralyse le secteur du logement pour
vous répondre la parole est au ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu merci monsieur le président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
müerbrun le rapport du Conseil d'analyse
économique auquel vous faites référence
du 10 janvier vous l'avez résumé à grand
trait parce que ce n'est pas exactement
ce qu'il dit ce qu'il dit c'est qu'il y
a une différence entre la consommation
théorique et la consommation réelle et
pour faire simple que plus les gens sont
dans des passoirs moins ils chauffent et
qu'à l'inverse des gens qui sont dans
des logements très isolés peuvent avoir
tendance à utiliser ce qu'on appelle un
effet rebond et donc avoir des
températures moyennes plus élevées et
des factures plus élevées et donc que la
baisse des émissions est parfois moins
forte compte tenu de l'impact sur les
factures et ça n'est pas sur 1000
personnes c'est sur 170000 logements
l'analyse du CAE conclut au fait que les
étiquettes sont cohérentes autrement dit
a c'est mieux que B qui est mieux que c
qui est mieux que D et je vous invite à
lire le rapport pas seulement les
articles de presse qui sont parus autour
et ensuite de préciser que c'est un
outil qui même si mesure un bien s les
attitudes ne modifi pas l'analyse de ce
qui a été refondu en
2021 1 nous avons besoin de faire des
travaux de rénovation pour des enjeux
climatiques mais aussi pour des enjeux
de pouvoir d'achat vous parlez des
propriétaire vous parlez des locataires
un locataire dans une passoire
énergétique en moyenne deux fois plus de
factures que quelqu'un qui est dans un
bien qui est de classes en dessous 2
vous évoquez les chiffres qui mélangent
les propriétaires occupants des
logements vacants plus de 10 % dans les
pass soir énergétique des résidences
secondaires et des locatifs qui sont les
seuls à être concernés par un calendrier
d'interdiction TR vous évoquez des
marges d'amélioration il y en a
plusieurs la formation des
diagnostiqueurs et des annonces que je
ferai dans quelques jours pour corriger
les biiaiais des DPE sur les petites
surfaces des biens de moins de 40 m² sur
lequel là nous avons matière sur la base
du rapport du CAE mais pas seulement à
améliorer le dispositif le Premier
ministre m'a autorisé dans quelques
jours à faire en sorte de préciser ces
nouvelles
règles madame
buerbron monsieur le ministre ce n'est
pas la première fois que l'on base une
politique majeure sur des modélisations
un peu fumeuses les Français perdent une
nouvelle fois confiance dans cette état
qui s'appuie sur un dispositif qui n'est
bienveillant ni pour eux ni pour la
planète hier j'ai entendu comme beaucoup
d'entre nous le président de la
République qui s'est inquiété de la
baisse de la natalité or la première
sécurité pour élever des enfants c'est
bien le logement
merci la parole est à notre collègue
colombe brossell pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre de l'Éducation
nationale alure où vos propos ont choqué
heurté blessé la communauté éducative
parlons école parlons de l'école de la
République l'école publque laïque
gratuite et obligatoire cette école
c'est celle qui scolarise 80 % des
élèves de ce pays d'où qu'ils viennent
qui qu'ils soi c'est vers elle que votre
énergie devrait être tournée afin de
garantir la réussite de tous lave comm
personnel car les défis sont immenses et
vous êtes au pouvoir depuis plus de 6
ans vous avez de fait posé la question
des parts de marché mise en concurrence
entre l'enseignement public et
l'enseignement privé cette mise en
concurrence n'est même pas libre et non
faussée aucun contrôle n'est effectué
par l'état des fond public qui finance
l'école privée et ce alors que
l'enseignement privé est financé à plus
de 70 % par l'État la Cour des comptes
très récemment vous rappelez à vos
obligations en la matière alors madame
la ministre quel moyen allez-vous enfin
donner à l'école publique pour la
[Applaudissements]
renforcer pour vous répondre la parole à
la ministre de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports madame oua
casterra merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice je crois que
vraiment on doit pas opposer l'école
publique et l'école privée depuis la loi
Debré du 31 décembre 59 adoptée sous la
présidence du général de Gaulle qui
établit la liberté d'enseignement dans
notre pays notre pays vit et notre pays
vit bien avec des écoles publiques et
avec des écoles privées les premières
accueillent 100 millions d'élèves les
autres 2 millions soit un élève sur 6 et
toutes deux concours au service public
de l'éducation dans les établissements
privés je le rappelle les programmes m
volumes horaires sont ceux du public
dans l'ensemble des établissements sous
contrat les enseignants sont rémunérés
par l'État et recrutés avec les mêmes
exigences de qualification que dans le
public 50 % des familles ont eu recours
au moins une fois à l'enseignement privé
pour au moins un de leurs enfants alors
je crois qu'il faut respecter ces choix
de scolarisation ne pas les stigmatiser
ne pas forcer les parents d'élèves à se
justifier mais comprendre ce qu'il y a
derrière leur décision et faire en sorte
que le choix d'une école publique ou le
choix d'une école privée ne soit pas la
résultante de déception ou de
frustration mais qu'elle corresponde ces
décisions à des vrais choix d'adhésion
pour tous au libre arbitre de chacun
pour l'école publique madame la
sénatrice j'ai la plus grande des
ambitions d'abord l'exigence à travers
le choc des savoirs l'autorité renforcée
de nos professeurs à travers toutes les
réformes que je vais poursuivre suite
aux impulsions données par Gabriel Atal
sur la revalorisation des carrières sur
les conditions de travail sur
l'organisation de nos remplacements pour
l'école privée je veux veiller à ce
qu'elle soit toujours et partout au
rendez-vous des principes et des valeurs
de la République et qu'on y renforce
aussi souvent que nécessaire le contrôle
pédagogique et que dans tout notre
service public de l'enseignement on
assure la cohérence de l'offre éducative
et la mixité sociale et scolaire
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
réussir l'école avec toute la communauté
éducative nous allons le faire nous
allons le faire faire réussir toutes les
écoles de notre pays je vous
remercie madame la
sénatrice merci pardon madame la
ministre peut-être que c'est pas d'usage
de parler avec son cœur dans un
hémicycle mais pardon de vous dire à
quel point il est troublant que vous
soyez incapable de répondre à la
question simple que je vous ai posée
vous vous êtes être mise toute seule
dans une situation qui est faite de
polémique et de mensonge et votre
impuissance aujourd'hui celle que vous
projetez elle est délétaire pour l'école
elle est délétare alors que les enfants
les enseignants l'ensemble des
personnels les parents ont besoin de
force ont besoin de confiance les
solutions elles existent recruter des
profs remplaçants dans le primaire pour
que on ait des remplaçants pour les
absences de courte durée annuler toutes
les suppressions de postes qui ont été
proposées ici même pendant le budget
2024 la mixité mais enfin on l'a fait
vivre dans nos territoires quand on fait
des secteurs multicollège quand on
adosse le financement privé à la mixité
sociale et scolaire prenez vos
responsabilités et faites vivre enfin
l'école de la République l'école de la
confiance c'est la confiance dans
l'école l'école de la confiance c'est la
confiance dans l'école
publique la
parole est au président
jean-fçois groupe les républicains
monsieur le
Président Monsieur monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre à partir du 22
janvier et pour une durée d'un mois des
centaines de pêcheurs français seront
empêchés d'exercer leur activité dans le
golfe de Gascogne 600 navires sont
concernés ce mois s'empêche pour les
français contrairement à leurs collègues
de l'Union européenne proposé par le
gouvernement est durci par le Conseil
d'État sous la pression des associations
environnementales enant préservver les
populations de petit cétacé des prises
accidentelles ce mois s'empêche c'est un
nouveau coup porté à toute une filière
qui depuis des années tente de surmonter
un à un les obstacles qui se dressent
face à elle entre les impacts du brexit
et la mise en place d'un plan de sortie
de flotte entre l'envolé des prix du
gasoil des quotas de plus en plus
restrictifs et des importations en
hausse constantes c'est bien la pêche
française qui est désormais en voie de
disparition nos marins leurs familles et
de ain toute la filière aliotique vont
continuer à souffrir malgré tous les
efforts consentis depuis 30 ans il
s'équipent progressivement pour palier à
toutes les contraintes qu'on leur impose
l'incompréhension les gagne ne veut-on
pas valoriser le travail et ils sont
empêché de travailler et paradoxe
naissant en Bretagne on réfléchit à
importer par avion du poisson pêché à
8000 km de nos côtes la plateforme
d'indemnisation qui a été mise en place
pour compenser le manque à gagner des
pêcheurs atténuera partiellement la
douleur elle ne concernera pas toute la
filière elle ne guérira pas la maladie
compensée n'est pas une perspective
d'avenir monsieur le ministre après
l'industrie et l'agriculture avec la
pêche encore un fleuron français garant
de l'autonomie qui souffre il est grand
temps de changer de cap qu'avez-vous à
dire aux pêcheurs et à leur
famill pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
monsieur le Président
Rapin l'émotion dont vous faites part
elle est d'abord née d'une décision du
Conseil d'État le 22 décembre dernier et
vous n'êtes pas en train de commenter ce
que serait une décision gouvernementale
mais au contraire la censure par le
Conseil d'État d'une tentative de
concilier ce qui é à la fois un enjeu de
préservation de la biodiversité avec un
risque de disparition du Dauphin et du
marsoin commun et de l'autre la
possibilité de poursuivre une activité
de pêche qui participe à notre
souveraineté le compromis il avait
consisté à la fois à tenir compte d'une
mesure d'arrêté
spatio-temporel en permettant des
dérogations qui étaient lié à des
équipements simplement controverse
scientifique sur l'impact de ces
équipements certains répulsifs Sonor
comp tenu de l'intelligence du dauphin
étant accusé de provoquer le fait que
les dauphins se rapprochent des bateaux
équipés des répulsifs au lieu au
contraire de s'en éloigner et les
chiffres monsieur le Président sont
préoccupants avec plus de échouage le
consensus c'est que c'est entre 5000 et
10000 c'est assez qui Meur et à ce
niveau de mortalité les risques sur la
viabilité d'une espèce qui participe
aussi à l'ensemble de l'équilibre dans
le Gold de Gast COG sont réels et avérés
pour la survie de
l'espèce face à ça et face à cette
décision du 22 décembre le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est comment accompagner
une filière et comment dans les semaines
et les mois qui viennent construire
trouver un équilibre en ayant à la fois
le souci de la biodiversité celui vous
décrivez de ces femmes et de ces hommes
dont je n'ignore pas parce qu'il s'agit
pas seulement d'un gagnepin mais d'une
philosophie d'une vocation d'une façon
de vivre c'est l'ambiance des ports je
pense évidemment à ceux que vous
connaissez je pense à la Vendé je pense
au golf de Gascogne de manière générale
ce sont des centaines de bateaux de plus
de 8 m qui sont concernés nous nous
battons en ce moment et nous allons nous
battre pour la partie compensation mais
nous aurons très vite à nous retrouver
avec les représentants des filières pour
au-delà de ce mois de fermeture
spaciotemporelle regardez les les choses
de façon plus posée et plus constructive
pour le moyen terme monsieur le
Président
rppa merci merci monsieur le ministre
vous avez répondu techniquement à ma
question je vous en remercie mais
néanmoins je pense que au-delà de ce que
vous avez exposé il y a bien sûr l'enjeu
des familles et finalement sur le
littoral sur tous les territoires la
question de la pêche elle est elle est
valable dans le golf de Gascogne et
demain elle sera à nouveau un sujet
d'actualité prignant avec le brexit sur
la mancheste mer du Nord et la Bretagne
donc monsieur le ministre aujourd'hui
les enjeux liés à la mer n'ont-ils pas
valeur suffisante pour avoir un ministre
un ministère de plein
exercice la paraule est à notre collègue
Nadia solgoup pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste monsieur le Président Mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'Agriculture il y a un an
exactement un texte était adopté à
l'unanimité des deux chambres ici au
Sénat au cours de la discussion générale
précédant son adoption Olivier dussot
alors ministre du Travail avait dit au
nom du gouvernement nos agriculteurs et
agricultrices plus largement les
Français et les Françaises nous
attendent sur cet horizon de justice
sociale ce texte c'était celui qui
visait à calculer la retraite de base et
non salarié agricoes en fonction des 25
années d'assurance les plus avantageuse
et non plus sur l'ensemble de la
carrière cette loi promulguée le 14
février 2023 comporte un article unique
et dispose que dans un délai de 3 mois à
côté de sa promulgation le Gouvernement
remettra au Parlement un rapport
précisant les modalités de sa mise en
œuvre ce rapport présentera notamment le
détail des scénarios envisagés des
paramètres retenus pour son application
ainsi que le cas échéant les
dispositions législatives et
réglementaires qu'il convient de
modifier bref ce rapport doit donner
tous les éléments qui permettront à la
MSA de commencer cet énorme chantier or
à ce jour un ans après pas de rapport
dès lors les associations
professionnelles agricooles et la MSA
alertent sur le fait que dans ces
conditions le dispositif ne sera
probablement pas opérationnel dans le
délai prévu par la loi alors Monsieur le
Ministre aujourd'hui je relaye cette
question où en est ce rapport tant
attendu et quand sera-t-il remis au
Parlement je vous remerci bravo N
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture
monsieur
F merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénateur madame la
sénatrice group merci de votre question
ça me permet de faire un point vous
l'avez dit c'est un sujet important
parce que c'est un sujet à la fois de
justice c'est un sujet de reconnaissance
et puis aussi un sujet d'attractivité
d'ailleurs au moment où nous allons
parler de renouvellement des générations
vous dire déjà ce qui a été fait grâce à
vous d'ailleurs les lois chassigne 1 et
chassigne 2 des éléments qui ont permis
de revaloriser le minimum de pension de
75 à 8 5 % c'est 115 € de plus par mois
pour de près 200000 pensionnés de rendre
plus équitable le calcul de la pension
minimale c'est 200000 retraités qui sont
concerné retraité agricole dont 70 % de
femmes on sait à quel point la situation
des femmes était très défavorable sur
les pensions agricoles et puis la
réforme des retraite portée par Olivier
duop effectivement qui a permis aussi de
revaloriser un certain nombre de choses
je pense aux exploitants qui sont partis
à la retraite au titre de l'invalidité
ou du handicap et c'est 45000 retraités
qui sont concernés là aussi donc on a
avancé et on a avancé collectivement et
c'est l'occasion de le dire et puis il y
a le projet loi la proposition de loi
pardon de Julien div sur laquelle vous
attendez un certain nombre de réponses
je je dois à la vérité de dire que le
ministère de l'Agriculture interrogé à
l'époque sur le moment où nous pourrions
rendre le rapport avait dit 3 mois nous
pensons que ça va être une grande
difficulté pourquoi parce qu'on sait
qu'il a un certain nombre de données qui
manquaient on sait très bien la MSL a
dit qu'il y avait une difficulté à
reconstituer les carrières et que donc
ça serait assez difficile je suis en
mesure de vous dire que nous allons
pouvoir rendre publici le rapport à la
fin du mois de janvier 2024 début du
mois de février pour être précis que on
ne croit pas que je veille faire malice
sur ces sujets là mais il fallait du
temps pour le faire et donc on va faire
un certain nombre de propositions je
vrais dire que c'est évidemment un sujet
très complexe parce que quand on modifie
autant que cela sur les 25 années il y a
un risque qui est des perdants beaucoup
et des gagnants qui soient mal
identifiés donc c'est pour ça que ça
prend du temps j'assume qu'on a pris du
temps pour faire des choses en bon ordre
et des choses sérieuses il y a deux
pistes qui peuvent être envisagé me
semble-t-il mais on en reparlera et vous
sera associé à ce travail la première
c'est application de la réforme au seuls
nouveaux entrants et puis procéder à une
double deuxème option procéder à une
double liquidation sur la base des
règles actuelles pour les périodes
antérieures à 2016 et pour les périodes
par rapport à après 2016 sur la période
sur les les références de 25 années
c'est là-dessus que nous travaillons et
c'est là-dessus que nous échangerons
nous allons approcher du but pour
effectivement rendre justice aux
agriculteurs
madoup écoutez monsieur le ministre je
suis très contente moi je m'apprêtais à
raller très fort dans ma réplique mais
alors tout va bien parce que c'est vrai
que fin janvier début février je je
m'attendais pas à une réponse aussi
favorable voilà vous avez compris qu'on
sera très attentif quand même parce que
chaque semaine qui manque là on a quand
même perdu beaucoup de moin initialement
la la réforme devait s'appliquer au 1er
janvier 2024 bon donc on a quand même
perdu du temps chaque semaine va manquer
à la Messa c'est extrêmement complexe
donc maintenant on attend que ça
aboutisse très très vite vous avez
compris l'enjeu c'est extrêmement
important
merci mais Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
merci
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
au Gouvernement nos prochaines questions
auront lieu le 24 janvier à 15h je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h30 pour la désignation des 23 membres
de la commission d'enquête portant sur
la production la consommation et le prix
de l'électricité la séance est
suspendue